et c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir le mali obtient gain de
cause la cour de justice de l'uemoa a
tranché les sanctions imposées par la
cedeao peuvent être suspendus cela
pourrait bien changer beaucoup de choses
pour le pays mais attention la décision
n'est pas exécutoire en tout cas pas
pour le moment nous en parlerons avec
anne fleur lespiau notre correspondante
à bamako est avec nous en plateau
et s'il sera question de la transition
mali lors du sommet de la cedeao
vendredi si les chefs d'état réunis
accra évoqueront sans doute la situation
au burkina faso deux mois tout juste
après le putsch de moi aussi de
privation de liberté pour le président
déchu roch marc christian kaboré nous
évoquerons la situation de l'ex
président avec la militante de toujours
germaine pitroipa qui est notre invité
ce soir
puis le prêt des traits dialogue se
poursuit entre le gouvernement tchadien
et les groupes politico-militaires à
doha le qatar a été désigné médiateur
nous irons à n'djamena à la fin de ce
journal
c'est une décision qui rebat les cartes
à la veille du sommet de la cedeao ou la
cour de justice de l'uemoa demande la
levée des sanctions imposées au mali des
sanctions décidé le 9 janvier dernier et
qui ont eu un impact conséquent sur
l'économie du pays la procédure avait
été initiée par les avocats de l'état
malien alors pour bien comprendre
l'uemoa c'est l'union économique et
monétaire ouest africaine elle est
constituée de huit pays tous appartenant
à la cedeao anne fleur vous êtes notre
correspondante à bamako est ce qu'on
peut parler de victoire pour la junte
malienne au pouvoir tout à fait monia on
peut même dire que c'est la première
victoire des autorités de transition qui
ont entamé
des négociations avec la cedeao depuis
maintenant deux mois des négociations
qui s'apparentait à un bras de fer vous
le savez ces sanctions étaient jugées
comme étant illégal et illégitime par le
premier ministre mais malien choguel
kokalla maïga
et quelque part la cour de justice de
l'uemoa vient de lui donner raison en
ordonnant la suspension de ces sanctions
cette décision elle intervient la veille
d'un sommet de la cedeao ce vendredi
cette réunion se tiendra à accra au
ghana un sommet auquel le président de
la transition et nouvel homme fort du
pays le colonel simi goïta a été invitée
finalement et dépêchera son ministre des
affaires étrangères abdoulaye diop pour
le représenter et pour négocier avec ses
partenaires ouest africain la levée des
sanctions lors de la dernière venue de
la cedeao à bamako c'est vendredi et
samedi la cedeao avait proposé la fin de
la transition dans un délai allant de
douze à seize mois de son côté bamako
propose un délai incompressible
de 24 mois jusqu alors les autorités de
transition malienne tabler sur le
prolongement de la transition jusqu'à
cinq ans d'après les conclusions des
assises nationales de la refondation à
la fleur l'uemoa doit tenir une session
aussi ce vendredi en parallèle de cette
de ce sommet de la cedeao oui alors ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est la différence
entre les sanctions de l'uemoa et de la
cedeao mise en place en janvier de son
côté lui et moi a suspendu le mali de
ses organes et mis en place des
sanctions financières telles que le gel
des avoirs financiers de plus de 150
personnalités qui font partie des
autorités de transition malienne ainsi
que le gel des avoirs de l'état malien
des entreprises publiques et des
établissements financiers au niveau de
la banque centrale d'afrique ouest
africaine elle a également
annoncer sa solidarité avec les
sanctions annoncées le 9 janvier par la
cedeao à savoir la fermeture des
frontières avec le mali et la suspension
des échanges financiers et commerciaux
autres que les produits de première
nécessité alors l'impact réel de ces
sanctions s'observe via la hausse des
prix des denrées alimentaires comme le
sucre par exemple ou encore des produits
comme le ciment merci beaucoup à fleurs
lescure pour vos explications et on
comprend que la levée de ces sanctions
pourraient donner un bol d'air est bien
aux maliens et puis je rappelle que vous
êtes à paris après la suspension de
france 24 et de rfi au mali et pour
refermer cette page malienne ce triste
bilan établi par la minus ma près de 600
civils ont été tués l'an dernier dans
des violences imputés principalement
groupes djihadistes mais aussi aux
milices d'autodéfense et aux forces
armées 584 civile précisément tué en
2021 selon ce rapport de la minus main
et les violences se jihadistes et
l'instabilité sécuritaire c'est ce qui a
précipité la chute il ya tout juste deux
mois du président du burkina faso roch
marc christian kaboré le 24 janvier
dernier la junte militaire conduite par
le lieutenant colonel paul henri
sandaogo damiba renversé le chef de
l'état lui reprochant de ne pas avoir
endigué c'est violence djihadiste roch
kaboré est depuis placé en résidence
surveillée ce jeudi son parti qui a
réclamé sa libération immédiate
on écoute alassane bâ l'a50 des
présidents du mpp le mouvement du peuple
pour le progrès
le pvda rock moi qui suis à cabourg n
étant pas privé de liberté du fait de la
justice
le mpp
exige
par conséquent son élargissement
immédiat et sans condition aujourd'hui
ne peut le voir
que son médecin
ses aides de camp ces enfants
son épouse est sûre pour une heure
il n'a plus accès à son téléphone
voilà la situation que vit le président
gabonais aujourd'hui
très vite et ce soir germaine pitroipa
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes une
ardente militante sans cariste
représentant en france de l'union pour
la renaissance au burkina faso ma
première question avez vous eu des
nouvelles du président kaboré depuis le
24 une seule fois commencez par cécile
et tabac comme c'était depuis le début
je pouvais dire qu'à l'époque rebonds en
tout cas sa voix nous ne me paraissait
pas al alliés pas du tout mais un homme
ferme toujours sadi a malgré son calme
on a senti la femme était j'ai senti la
fermeté dans sa voix alors ça fait deux
mois aujourd'hui jour pour jour est-ce
que vous avez été surprise par ce cette
prise de pouvoir par les militaires
putschistes n'ont surprise surtout pas
surprise pourquoi vous pouvez pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas surpris parce
que je sais que
c'est ce quarteron de militaires qui
sont arrivés au pouvoir le 24
sont de ceux les anciens du lsp et le
sp.a de triste renommée même si
malgré le renversement du régime de
blaise compaore ce
ce régime a continué à s'organiser je
dis à tous ceux qui veulent kim et parle
de mauvaise gouvernance il ya des choses
qui n'ont pas été faites jeudi par
kaboré aurait pu mettre même la moitié
de ses amis
la totalité de sa famille en prison soit
disant pour mal gouvernance ce coup
d'état aurait eu lieu depuis l'échec de
gilbert diendiéré les général félon
depuis cet échec là le msp a considéré
que c'était un échec pour eux et d'une
manière ou d'une autre quand on voit
tout ce qui arrive autour de damiba on
voit que c'est le retour du cdp pourquoi
et pourquoi le lsp vais remettre en
cause l'insurrection des 30 et 31 passes
il considère que c'était eux qui étaient
les premiers visés mais bien sûr le chef
de l'état de l'époque blaise comparé
n'avait que eux comme militaire équipe
est armée est bien armé par rapport à
l'armée naga l'armée régulière donc
voilà pourquoi depuis et je pense que et
je leur conseillerais en tout cas s'il
m'écoute de libérer le président a
clairement kaboré alors s'attendre
justement le président du mpp vous
rejoindre en demander la libération du
président doivent le libérer s'il ils
sont vraiment venu pour soi-disant
restaurer
et promouvoir la réconciliation plus
garde le président mac que client kaboré
plus ils augmentent leurs sentiments est
ce que la cia où je voudrais pas faire
pression justement et chefs d'état dont
la visière de la cedeao bout j'en sais
rien parce que c'est un une organisation
vont même elle a le mérite seulement
d'exister et je comprends pas pourquoi
la cedeao reste silencieuse alors que
nous l'avons vu à l'activité en activité
lorsque le général félon gilbert guérin
et a tenté d'interrompre la sélection
alors on va revenir sur le cas de
gilbert diendéré on a entendu cet appel
en du npp à la libération immédiate mais
en même temps dans l'impression que
l'ump se divise plusieurs membres ont
quitté les rangs du parti présidentiel
comme quel regard vous portez ceux qui
ont fait le coup d'état savent très bien
ce stade je dis bien ils savent très
bien que un gardien le président marc
christian kaboré en fait ils font
pression sur le mpp et tous les alliés
du mpp c'est à dire quand il sera en
couleurs mais nous avons j'ai dit bien
nous les alliés ceux qui ont
effectivement était au pouvoir pendant
de 2015 à 2022 nous nous sommes liés par
le fait que nous avons des soucis nous
avons des inquiétudes sur le fait de sa
sécurité parce que pour des gens qui ont
tiré sur son véhicule
le 24 janvier n'avait pas tiré pour le
laisser vivants alors jean xxiii
pitroipa malheureusement on est pris par
le temps cette dernière question sur ce
procès des assassins de thomas sankara
il a repris cette semaine le général
diane déry et le principal accusé on
vous connaît on vous connaît pour votre
lutte avec acharnement aux connaître aux
côtés de thomas sankara donc les avocats
du général d'intérêt ont demandé
l'acquittement comment vous vivez ce
procès vous qui avez connu thomas
sankara est une étape nécessaire pour
que le pays puisse aller de l'avant
merci en tout cas merci et je profite de
l'occasion pour dire merci à ceux qui
ont permis que ce procès ait lieu
le général sur l'ancien enfin le général
félon gilles belzons guéret et tous ceux
qui sont devant là bas les bars
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal ne
s'attendait certainement pas à ce qu'il
y ait ce procès trente cinq ans nous
avons obtenu 35 ans et grâce à ceux qui
seront faits l'insurrection de trente 30
1 nous avons imposé ils ont imposé ce
procès là aussi bien à la transition
call ou à tous ceux qui ont suivi après
l'attentât après l'insurrection et merci
aux insurgés et je dis et je leur
conseille à tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui au pouvoir de faire
attention le clou burkinabè la jeunesse
burkinabè et les patientes mais de faire
attention et c'est pas pour rien qu'ils
aient rapidement ils ont bricolé quelque
chose pour la constitution parce qu'ils
avaient dit si vous avez suspendu la
constitution c'est pas pour rien ils ont
vite compris que si ce procès ne
reprenait pas il est risqué et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je leur conseille vivement
de libérer le président christian kaboré
et pour quoi et ça vous savez pourquoi
non non je continue vous savez pourquoi
ils ont peur on pourrait continuer
pendant bien longtemps je voulais mais
en france à 4 suit ce procès à des
assistants de thomas sankara et général
aura l'occasion de forêt invités seront
pour ballet août après je vous souhaite
de souhaitent de pouvoir inviter et je
vous remercie en tout cas de dire que
les général vient d'y aller c'est que ce
qu'il a fait et il sait c'est qu'il
risque merci merci merci mais d'une
façon il a habitué à la prison on ne
fera qu'ajouter les 21 10 qui est je
souhaite que
c'est qu'il a faim merci germaine
pitroipa je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant en france de l'union pour
la renaissance au burkina la halle et il
nous reste même si en direction
n'djamena le président rogge se poursuit
cette fois à doha entre les
représentants du gouvernement et les
groupes politico-militaires 52
mouvements finalement constitué en trois
groupes celui de doigts de du qatar et
de rome chacun reçu successivement par
le médiateur qatari qui va ensuite
renégocier avec la délégation
gouvernementale
les propositions qui ont été faites en
fait le point avec notre correspond
entre khadidja douga
aussitôt démarré aussitôt suspendu des
pourparlers entre le pouvoir et les
politico militaires tchadiens l'a
finalement réellement pas pu débuter ici
en tout cas les analystes politiques
tchadiens tiennent à souligner que la
plupart des groupes politico militaires
présents sur place ont déjà signé
quelques accords avec le gouvernement
tchadien et souhaite simplement se
mettre d'accord sur des accords de paix
afin de pouvoir rentrer n'djamena le 10
mai pour le pour participer au dialogue
national en ce qui concerne certains
groupes comme celui de rome parme dans
lequel on retrouve les rebelles du fat
désigné comme responsable du décès du
président idriss deby il s'agirait ici
de revoir profondément la charte de
transition l'eau problème de la révision
de la charte c'est surtout ça qui pose
problème pour ce groupe dont je parle de
points d'appel aux groupes
de roms ce groupe là faudrait d'abord
qu'on parle de la charte parce que la
charte quelques promulgué ce sont les
militaires et 15 militaires c'est pas au
nom du peuple tchadien donc il faut
diviser la charte il ne peut plus et
puis les civils inclure donc les
politico-militaires et tous ceux qui
veulent bien intégré nos processus mais
si la charte n'est pas révisée c'est
d'être les difficile pour certains de
plans de paris diallo des pourparlers
entre les politico-militaires et les
représentants du gouvernement tchadien
devrait se poursuivre encore plusieurs
jours à doha ici indiens mais n'a en
tous cas les avis sont très partagés
si une partie de la population veut bien
croire aux chances de réussite de ce
prêt dialogue beaucoup restent encore
très sceptique sur le processus et c'est
la fin du journal de l'afrique team
merci de votre fidélité merci à mes
invités belle soirée sur france 24
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau que nous consommons au sénégal